you and mike
grew up in the the same boxing scene
together and i have any
good memories with michael you guys were
kids
you still see that kid in him obviously
you guys are yeah
he was the same size as he is but now i
told everybody
[Music]
he was like
[Music]
so what's up everybody you guys welcome
to this episode of hop boxing with mike
tyson i am your co-host triple c aka
henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson our
guest here is a very special guest very
special in my heart because we grew up
boxing together and this is the mighty
mickey ward
yeah what's up everybody come on man
what's up
what's up
we got the legend
that means yeah that means you too how
you doing mike i'm doing good man but we
got you here man yeah exactly
you know so i met you i met you when i
was what like around 17 years you were
16. i was 17. yeah yeah and we were
fighting in um
placid new york oh wow we fought the
germans
no that was uh well the regionals
well that's when it's with the region
yeah they go to the nationals but did
somebody that i i wasn't in the past and
somebody fighting yeah yeah yeah well
then in the past i think okay that kid
got a little scared you gotta get scared
show up
yeah mickey in the back was showing me
some of the pictures have you seen him
mike yeah you and him like back you guys
were kids dude kids man right there you
still
uh uh what is it what do you guys call
it jersey
yeah he had i had the space coaster here
yeah
he looked good though right yeah he
looked like a fighter
the young kid he looks like this guy
yeah so tell us a little bit about
making a little bit of obviously man you
have a motion picture that's that's been
you know played by mark wahlberg tell us
a little about your life man for those
for everybody tuning in here a little
bit
well like i you know i grew up boxing uh
at a young age and my brother dickey
fought prior to me and
you know he think he was a good and uh
but drugs and stuff was just seeing the
movie got the best of him but uh it was
a great training stop him from being
beautiful though no 100
you know great beautiful heart
and stuff we can still see his beauty
love it i got on a ten percent you know
you know then i uh
did amateurs and stuff like that because
of him and the silver man the golden
gloves the abs like i fought with mike
and then uh
turned pro in 85 and
i never really thought i would do it as
a critter i thought i'd just do it to
see how far you can go or whatever you
know
then i kept winning and winning and top
rank signed me
and then i was fighting i got you know
the yeah i think i still got the record
to this day on espn 28 times
really yeah yeah 20 yeah 28 times what
fought on espn oh yeah
and uh
they don't have that many fights now so
i don't know no one could beat it
yeah they don't fight much now dude no
i'm backing up i remember fight one
concert one tournament next week you
know school to another
ohio fair you know another one in boston
from boston you go to the castle new
york then you go to new york city
yeah that was crazy it was just
everywhere you go you somebody's gonna
fight the reason we stay on vacation
we're looking for gyms or boxing clubs
where we can spar up a box of money it's
your whole life that's all you do and so
you're around fighters yeah and you
catch it you get their habits you see
how they dress you see how they conduct
themselves you see how the girls like
them see the calls they drive
yes you take a little piece out of
everybody it's like a puzzle box and
yeah you see this there you put it it's
a puzzle you'll never know everything
yeah you put enough together well i'm
saying that was so much inspiration and
seeing those guys
you know we come from nowhere and stuff
then we see guys like that
hey we could do that stuff too yeah see
i can do that
yeah because your brother your brother
dicky man like uh you know obviously
watching the
movie he fought he must have really been
opted by a really good boxing man he
fought sugar ray leonard yeah he fought
ray sugarey with sugar ray two years
after the olympics so i think it was
ray's uh second ten rounder yeah
you know when dickie um i thought he's
gonna blow him well he went ten rounds
with him he you know um he lost
obviously i knew his unanimous decision
but you know
you know ray said he gave him a hell of
a fight you know and uh they became
really you know close
[Music]
yeah i think he's dicky so
but right you know i'm already got you
know they get along good
yeah yeah have you had a chance to meet
his brother mike uh um i know who he was
when i was younger oh yeah yeah thank
you to albany new york fighting
someplace yeah i used to fight up in
albany troy you know yeah every troy yes
you know you'll fight yeah because
obviously i mean you guys grew up going
to amateur tournaments together right i
went to i went to a big national
tournament mike but
because we went to the regionals and i
won new england he won new york this
stuff was big when you're young like
this yeah this was back in the late 70s
right now early 80s 80s 83 3 4. listen
up 83 yeah that was so big you were in
the tournament everybody knew your face
i wasn't outstanding trophy i said wow
it's funny because when you're young
like that you don't when you when you're
a kid like they get nervous kind of
sometimes when you're around all the
people and wow you see he's this he's
that and all of a sudden you're sitting
there going oh no who am i fighting see
but you know i had the advantage of
saying because i had customers he was
the old guy and he see the person nelly
brothers and they all knew each other
when they were young back in the 40s and
stuff yeah and cuz just knew everybody i
had the opportunity to see everybody
spar and everything because of course
um yeah he really gave me a really um a
high platform
yeah so it's almost like you you took
some of that inspiration mike from a lot
of the
the professionals absolutely um even
their even their faults
i remember their faults what's causing
them to lose what caused them
to win
right it's nice to morph myself into
them
stop hanging out with girls stop getting
high
once you get that issue man it's it's
going to stay with you till you die yeah
exactly i still do not think i can fight
and then believe it too
um matter of fact i want to get into the
streets i want somebody to bother me i
know that sounds crazy huh
oh but that's just for you
you know what i mean that's
you grew up with it
you haven't done it in a long time
probably
so you're probably thinking let me see
if i'm still good my wife is always in
my way you know he's yelling at me and
stuff i'm just looking for somebody to
clock
yeah man you uh you finally win your
first uh world title was it in 96 or 97
no i i lost uh
i bought vince phillips i got i for the
ibf title and he caught me in the third
round and every one of every one of
crazy family right they're all like
they've the doctor starts to fight
and they're all throwing bears in the in
the thing in the ring right ah because
they have that this the stands were like
up here and the ring is down here
they're all throwing beer in the ring
and i'm like stop stop and vince is the
holding back hiding vents that only get
hit the cups not bottles but still it's
bare and everything you know
he's amazing man you're not good ain't
his fault you know whatever he goes he
didn't you know it's not his father
you're just trying to win you know
yeah so he kind of calmed down and still
you got to calm down and stuff and you
know well that guy's still alive vince
yeah yeah yeah yeah he was a good big he
had a big right hand he's a good puncher
very good fighter did anybody ever throw
uh any anybody ever throw things at you
mike when you're walking out to the ring
right hell yeah yeah what's the question
for the crazy [ __ ]
what's the come on the crazy [ __ ] they
thrown at you um
whatever they had in their hand or
whatever they were drinking
i'm the kind of guy i fight the fans
like somebody see the fans saying boys
i'm coming [ __ ] you a [ __ ] i get
upset i'm coming they [ __ ] jet
[ __ ]
the the legendary the legendary fights
of you and art of god you oh they're
from [ __ ] carnage what do you call
them in four fights i mean they're four
fights or three three it was three
fights
three fights in 13 months
that's real fighting yeah that's real
fighting yeah yeah yeah it's a lot of
fighting that's a trick
you barely had a chance to train very
little time to train isn't that
something maybe a little tiny get out of
shape so yeah yeah
but jesus maybe yeah maybe take like a
week off right and then back back at it
and camp yeah i think yeah
for that three period they fought more
than they trained huh probably yeah they
fought more than they trained
a lot has changed how have you seen the
boxing world right now coming together
making it like what's uh
what do you think about these boxers not
fighting each other i mean that's that's
the biggest
thing these guys what happened to the
fighter's ego i mean my ego is too big
to have somebody else be champion i'm
cheating
i get into a fight with him in the
street i want those guys to fight the
guys
oh
[Music]
god
jesus what round is that
third
oh no
my hips hurt the next day i said imagine
man
mike when he went down i'm saying to
myself don't get up don't kill him
please i was saying the same [ __ ] stay
down
and the guys were free and now they stop
that fight frank's like no no fight
ain't over
yeah what were you thinking that round
we got clocked with a little what are
you thinking
i wasn't it
would happen mike was like i said i was
uh so dazed when i was against the robes
but but when he hit me
he woke me up
seriously like my legs were still gone
but my brain was like more i i knew
where i was where when i was days i was
like out of here that's the brush
and said that's what happened when they
fought
carmen basilio yeah he was pulling me
down to come in and boom boom he got up
to boo yeah yeah the doctor said that
your brain and go back into like
your legs will still be gone but your
brain will be normal like you you know
where you're focused like it's crazy
yeah
but the thing is you just have to stay
there and take it and
try to fight it's for the same reason
why i think and i feel that box is more
dangerous than mma
because of the glove that you guys have
one
mma glove that has that's four ounces
will will knock you out like quick yeah
but with a boxing glove with somebody
that really knows how to properly hit
yeah
you'll probably take them off
that may make up small he might get hit
hard and the fights a little bit shorter
but the the longer the fight
boxing you're getting pounded pounded
for longer 12 rounds and we're back at
15 back in years ago if you're if we're
boxing 15 around 12 round with those
gloves we'll break our hands yeah yeah
no but the same thing you guys would be
knocking each other out within a punch
well listen yeah i think the within the
first round my hands would be broken oh
100 did you break your hands a lot mike
when you're uh competing fractured them
a lot
do you ever fight with a broken hand
yeah you don't feel it the next day yeah
exactly and then i noticed this if you
have a bad habit that's broken hit him
to the body it still hurts yeah i didn't
think it hurt because it only hurt me
but it still hurts when you punch him
through the body oh hitting the prayer
yeah if you have a broken hand he's
punched to the body the head's gonna
make your hand up and elbows go right to
the body you say it nothing numbs up
yeah i broke my thumb and come off the
bone like that the tendon
you know and reno nevada i fought and uh
supposed to fight chavez that night yeah
chavez the shabbos got sick or something
they had he pulled out or whatever high
energy so i fought as a mexican kid from
uh louis castillo for a month
from l.a man was he tough
and i calm in the second round what the
[ __ ] my that tendon snapped on my bone
but i fought with her because i didn't
feel it it went numb next morning but
then when i took it out out of the glove
that night
and then i had to get it sewed back
together like yeah did you go to okay so
you had to go under surgery yeah yeah
they did like day surgery and put it
back together how did your family doing
children what's going on my daughter's
doing good yeah yeah that's good
there came a time uh mickey where you
you went through losing streak and you
decided to let go of the sport of boxing
man and start you know you decided to be
what is a paver yeah i did that before i
did it when i was when i was fighting
too asphalt
and stuff um
but uh yeah i know what i did like i was
fighting i was winning one and winning
and then once you start losing like one
or two fights then all of a sudden
everyone kind of like all right
you're not making the money no more i'm
gonna go
i'm gonna not sign him or whatever you
know i mean they look at you in a
different way
yeah i said so i said that the hell
would i say we're all used up we can't
use it yeah so i said the hell would it
i'm not getting used uh i was i was
fighting for the wrong reasons i was
fighting
just for the wrong reasons you know i
mean one and i can when i came back i
came back on the way my terms away i
wanted to fight or what i wanted to do
and it worked out you know but
when when you lose a fight you're
supposed to take a few fights easy ones
get your confidence back you won't get
your confidence back but i kept getting
i lost i get thrown in with a tougher
guy lose again go 12 rounds 10 runs get
thrown in with a tougher guy you know i
was getting at a young age i was
fighting guys like
frankie warren 12 runs you know little
guy texas typhoons tough as nails
him like
harold brazier
guy veteran like jersey right yeah he
[ __ ] throwing with guys like that and
i said how would i'm not getting used
i'm i'm leaving yeah as i'd rather do
i'd rather do construction and get beat
up so you know what i mean and you and
you did that for how long did it for a
while uh yeah i was off fighting three
three and a half years
when i came back that's when everything
went up then the sanchez fight kind of
propelled me yeah you know after beating
him he was
he was top ranked new man you know he
was um
he was the mexican kid that was like in
line for the next big one and uh he took
him out yeah but he beat the shot at me
every every second of every round
if i landed that one left hook to the
live one that's all i needed yeah when
he went down stand him again i'm like
there was no there wasn't no mexican
heavyweights for mike like there's it's
rare no
you know
those dudes are like they don't stop
mike
all day
yeah yeah yeah
man he was tough he could punch hard
mexican boston almost like it's a battle
of like endurance yeah to them if i
didn't hit him in the body i would have
lost they were going to stop the fight
like he comes in my corner you got to
show me something we're going to stop
and say don't laugh and stop i said i'll
show you something i didn't know if i
can show him it but i was going to try
yeah you know what i mean if the referee
stops it so be but i ain't gonna stop
quitting her you know whatever i don't
know i just yeah so mickey but you you
you had a rough patch uh wrap uh rough
patch there for a minute because
obviously you know uh watching the film
what now you started drinking and uh
yeah i drank i yeah i drink after fights
and stuff i never drank before a fight
ever once before a fight or anything
like that never i you know i i wasn't
that dicky would drink i could have
until the week other fight
i never drank i trained i i always do
anything
to the face yeah
yeah maybe if you didn't smoke it baby
it hurt you worse cause your body was so
used to it huh yeah
you know when you start smoking mike
when when you started a kid no i know
that but did you always smoke when you
like when you're right before yeah
well you're smoking mike briefly huh i
smoked one for tony tucker
mike was just smoking behind the olympic
training center
the man man
he lost to robert shannon in the fight
robert yeah he was tough lefty
right yeah tell me about your hand with
the police uh yeah don't tell me your
police officers started um obviously it
got worse and i had to get this
bone taken out of my uh hip and put in
there
and i got three two screws in there but
uh dr michaels did a great job on my
hand and what happened
from that you know it started off with
the
the cops
handcuffed
no they'll build the the flashlight
boom the flash and the big long flash
like that and in my head that's eight
stitches in my head
and my hand
but you said i fought myself
you started fighting the cops no i
didn't fight him at all no i was just
dicky was getting arrested
and i went over and they see me going
over and they thought i was gonna do
something but i wasn't so they grabbed
me
and then that was it oh so it was an
accident though
well they're probably not mine
no because you're right a cop doesn't
know what you know what i'm saying and
then i've seen the and the funny thing
is i've seen a couple years later mike
listen the cops know who everybody is
they know they they had trouble with
dickie before oh hundred percent dick
yeah
yeah
yeah that's why that's why they grabbed
him because he was getting in trouble
all the time
some cops don't like people they're
human beings some people irritate them
yeah you know he was getting a lot of
trouble then whatever and i don't know
it's just one of those things i was in
the wrong place at the right time i
guess
i can i can only imagine
those flashlights are like six pounds
they're heavy maybe 10. yeah
well everyone hit me in the head that
eric well i didn't get dazed me but if
everything went cold
it was like ice on my head
yeah okay
you got a lawsuit against these guys no
i didn't do it now
you i don't i don't know yeah it wasn't
worth it
yeah you you've been you've been able to
have your but that was cool i'm cool
with them all night i get along with
them all now i was just
you know i the guy that did i seen him
years later and i said listen if i if
you thought i was going to do something
i never was going to do anything like
this but
you know
you know i just you know i hold no
grudge or whatever you know i don't want
to deal with that for the rest of my
life you know i mean that ain't whatever
he says mickey thank you so much for
doing that you're moving man to me and
you know the guy's all right he was just
in a bad predicament yeah you talk about
the cops yeah then that's that's crazy
what are you gonna do yeah you know i
mean it's over
you can't bring it back yeah
don't let it don't let your past dictate
your future right
yeah and and uh your brother dickie he's
still alive he passed yeah no no he's
still alive
he ain't dying yeah yeah
hey yeah if the stuff he's done and
jumped out of windows and stuff all that
stuff
right i got a funny story i gotta tell
you
mike i got a funny story i gotta tell
you
we're watching the movie the fighter
with mark wahlberg christian bale up and
paramount pitches on
whatever like about six months before it
came out for like a dry run
so the pot with dickie jumping out of
the window right he's he's like he's
looking out like this so mark goes like
this to me goes look at your brother you
think he's gone like he didn't do it so
the movie gets over and so marx is the
dicky dicky when you are jumping out of
the window look you were looking like
you didn't do it he goes yeah i did it
but i went off the third floor not the
second
he said there's no barrels
yeah the fighter the fighter mickey like
it's is it surreal for you to hear that
you have a featured film about your life
with an a-list celebrity yeah it's crazy
because uh you know christian bale won
the academy award named um melissa leo
went on academy while playing my mom
yeah you know and that's crazy you know
i know that's that kid small small
skinny white kid from low light
you know what i mean like um boxing gave
you yeah you know what i mean so i never
knew anything like that would happen i
just
but
that's just i guess it was my fate i
guess
i never knew anything like that would
happen it's just it happened it was like
it was great the movie came out great
and uh
like you know
chris the last name was christa doodle
stanley
no that's a referee yeah yeah yeah the
other guy i think that was a greek name
he was a greek guy oh christopher
no he was with the boxing gloves all the
time yeah had to be him 156 at 165 now
yeah around that time 165.
those are a few guys
there's so many people that fought
through there
because you weren't that true there yeah
the wings you weren't you [ __ ] did you
you fought no out of the wing i won i
won the golden no i know i didn't want
to go you won the opens yeah but when i
went i was a fighter lost in the final
not no no not low but
in the nationals yeah
yeah nationals and you beat them with a
guy
jim bisson
that big white guy know my name i forgot
bison the big big big white guy i forgot
i might go again stashed him in one
round oh yeah 30 seconds bomb
that was it
yeah everyone's like
looking at it
holy shoot
yeah mike just walked in
there
was there a lot of knockouts back in the
amateur and those yeah
right yeah yeah girls he didn't he you
know
yeah
because he mike was
like a punch like micah punch but what
was more about mike was it was his speed
and accuracy yeah
his speed of his punches was that's what
speeds his power and that's when he had
you know what i mean there's little
punches those little six inch punches
yeah
the sequel the five they're trying to uh
they're trying to do a part two here huh
well i'm talking about it
yeah hopefully it gets done
wonderful yeah if we get that going with
the
the trilogy with gaddy and the
friendship and being a toro and
because we became
best of friends you know he was a
beautiful person yeah he was a great guy
you know he was crazy like anybody else
but
he had a biggest heart you want to you
know you could see the heart he had in
boxing but his heart was even bigger on
the on the outside of the ring he just
won't love it everybody wouldn't be
loved yeah great guy
that's pretty cool what do you think of
jamie foxx playing mike in his for his
movie
yeah
well the thing yeah i will say yeah
that's my huh yeah it should be good man
i hope it's great i hope so too yeah it
has to be there it has to every
every good boxing movie is always you
know they become part of america yeah
you know the rocky movies
i like gentlemen jim but um
what was that guy named of a guy's name
what's the guy in my son errol flynn
playing he played gentleman jim corga it
was beautiful
the fighting sucked but just the message
was beautiful
life after boxing mickey how's it
obviously you know you wrote obviously
your movie your book uh yeah you're uh
you know you're you're doing
motivational speaking now yeah doing
that i don't want live training though
you know um
you know like a live training app you
can train with anybody anywhere in the
world
tell me a little bit tell us a little a
little bit about that i always talk to
your business partner man it seems like
it's uh yeah it's some cool
revolutionary stuff now you get to try
it oh good it's you know you can train
live with any of the trainers from
wrestling to mma
wrestling boxing mma will start out when
uh training with the best
in the world olympians uh world
champions
a lot of big names on the platform so
yeah we're gonna be launching it soon so
yeah no you guys are basing it off with
three sports right boxing wrestling mma
style right now we're gonna start out
with that and then we're gonna branch
off into like
live shows and different things like
that
yeah will be big plus i got mickey wood
apparel company that's cool man
hopefully hopefully that hopefully it
takes off because it's really uh i think
it's really it's a new idea that could
really uh
hop on and revolutionize sports man yeah
100 you know
and you can just if you if you want to
talk to a fighter that's on the on the
thing
you don't have to do a boxing training
or a wrestling thing you can talk to
someone just ask them more like a
motivational thing for a half hour or
how did you feel in this fight when you
were knocked down or you whatever
whatever you know what i mean yeah maybe
analyze film too yeah that too yeah
content all that kind of different
content yeah like i said i got the
mickey ward apparel yeah you got your
own clothing line man so life has really
uh the transition from boxing out to
life
how's that transition been for you easy
you got it there's a lot of projects for
you glad i'm not getting hit no more
people say you miss it i say no
i missed a i missed the condition of
mike i missed like
i got the cte
fight
post concussion
so i can't inspire anymore i wouldn't
would have liked to maybe uh but i can't
get hit no more
and i'm actually donating my brain when
i pass because i'm in that study mike
what the [ __ ] with the football players
and all that yeah he's like i mean i'm
good with it because i stay healthy and
stuff you know i mean so and all that
but uh there's a lot of guys out there
that don't remember their own name or
walk right before understanding you know
what i mean and it's sad you know what i
mean but uh so i said
i tell you what make it for you for
being a lotto uh for being in a lot of
wars when i just saw that and you know
all the fights
man i wouldn't you know if people didn't
annoy me like i don't know if he's you
know yeah and i'm good i'm good my wife
can see it because i get like angry
there's differences there's different
things with concussions because people
can go to drink and drugs people do this
people want to hurt people people want
to be here whatever it might be like
there's all different effects from
concussions
people get tired people get angry people
get whatever it is yeah did you get any
surgeries with that gaudy fight yeah
yeah double like my eye that's right too
and the third fight he caught me in the
ninth round like oh no it's not that
night it was a seventh or something a
left hook on top of the head boom
my brain shifted in my skull made my eye
muscles go out of whack so i've seen
double for um
from seventh round to the tenth
and i was uh and i couldn't stop oh my
god i'm saying a dicky i'm gonna cause i
think i could see three of them
i can't see right there's only about
that what the [ __ ] you mean don't worry
about it i gotta i can't fly i guess i
was hardly fighting one on my three
you know
yeah
no but yeah i was funny he like you're
all right you're all right you're all
right yeah i'm all right
i ain't gonna stop howard you know i
just kept going so i had to get a double
surgery and a year later they had to cut
here and cut here and pull the eye
muscles together so i can see because if
i see i look that was double that's deep
yeah man so
that was which which
yeah
you know we do get it we don't be seeing
it happen before we know it can happen
to us yeah yeah you know what's gonna
happen but it's just i guess it's a
fight in your chance you're gonna take
uh
that's what we're
i mean i fighting yeah
i don't know i guess it is in your mind
away and it's not i don't know it's uh
you just got to keep going yeah
so you can't go anymore
yeah
yeah growing up a girl obviously you and
mike you and mike are you know grow up
in the the same boxing scene together do
you have any
good memories with michael you guys were
kids do you want your song you still see
that kid in him obviously you guys are
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was
he was the same with size as he is but
now i told everybody
i mean he was like yeah he was very
tall
yeah no but i mean body wise everything
he was like
he was like powerful and um
like i said you know what the way cuss
trained and what that
that fast head movement those short
punches
that was with that it's not the one
punches that's the combination of
punches
it's a
and the thing is you you do to be an
inside fighter you do have to take risks
oh yeah yeah
it takes
when you take risks that's exciting
yeah you have to man you put on you put
on some great great fights mickey
but now your career now obviously is you
know we go back and we probably think
philanthropy man what do you do to help
out a lot of the you're still involved
with the sport of boxing
yeah yeah i helped my nephew at his gym
you know and uh at box to burn in
westfield mass and uh
you know i'm with that live train now
and so
trying to give back to like fighters and
people like through that specifically
box you know you you know i heard you
get you do a lot of philanthropy for
them like uh yeah you know the advice
stuff because you can't yeah that's some
motivational advice um
he's gonna tell kids that
boxing you don't play boxing for number
one it's like not like another sport
you can't pass the ball or something or
you can't pass your gloves to this guy
are you going this round this one
you just got to train your ass off you
got to win that fight right here in the
gym
you you wouldn't read there
obviously in the ring you're all the
iggy henry's yeah
but you wanted those
month two mo two months of training you
win it right there yeah like we were
talking about earlier
what about what about the preparations
what about those fighters that can't say
goodbye to the sport
you know
i don't know i mean like what would you
like a conversation like that with
somebody how do you knock sense into
something that's that's really broken
you can't re-fix
it well i mean if it it's a different
thing as if if you want to come back and
fight
like mike now you do the exhibition
that's fine yeah
but if you want to go go in there and
compete at that level that you used to
compete no come on man do you know me
mike yeah
i mean you might have a you know i have
a puncher's chance mike always might
could be a punches chancellor he's 99.
it's got um you know what i'm saying but
if you gotta do this and like you got
the repetition this stuff yeah is it
it's not friendly with you when you
don't practice with it no you're gonna
practice practice and i don't know i
think they're
obviously the older you get when you
slow down a little bit yeah absolutely
i'm gonna see what happens when i hit
this
punching bag
oh yeah but no you can hit the bags hard
fast but then the bag ain't coming back
at you yeah i know
you know what i mean like yeah you know
you know we know better than i do the
first they spawn i got the [ __ ] kicked
back yeah
holy [ __ ]
yeah i never said hey what the [ __ ] am i
doing i knew i belonged here but i just
knew i had to change something up
what words of encouragement do you have
for mickey here mike
mickey is just doing the right thing you
know god has touched him do so many good
things in his life and to attract so
many good people around him
you know he's he's doing really good
and my my perspective yeah not bars and
nobody others
ain't got nobody chasing him for money
or anything he ain't getting it anyways
[Laughter]
yeah michael we have millions of people
man watching uh watching this episode
man everybody i think everybody's making
war founder you know what message you
got what message you got for your fans
and you want to close the show out here
yeah message for my fans just
thanks for all the years of sticking by
me most of them some of them you know i
mean because a lot of them when you're
winning they're on it yeah yeah yeah
when you lose off okay what are you
doing this for but all the real fans
thank you for sticking behind me um
it was a great run i gave everything i
had and um
thank you for staying by my side and
help me
from afar you know
i like that
yeah
and there you have it guys that's
we come to an end you guys thank you for
watching this episode of hot box with
mike tyson i'm your co-host triple c aka
henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson and this
is where it ends right here brother
taking mickey ward take us out thank you
we out yes
[Music]
you